monday p-f-t-o-t chris sims mike florio
chaotic sunday in the nfl and uh we
could keep we could keep talking about
it all day yeah there's a lot about
later on chris sims unbuttoned yep i'll
be talking about some of it tomorrow on
pftpm but but a few things that we kind
of touched on during breaks and we
didn't have a spot to really jam it in
to a very very tight outline for the two
hours that we had on nbcsn one deals
with the saints it's a given at this
point drew brees is going to be out yeah
for a while for at least a little bit
right yeah thumb
ligament
maybe surgery whatever the case may be
he's not going to be able to play
for a while so
what do you do at quarterback yeah if
you're in new orleans saints you have
teddy bridgewater you have taysom hill
yeah you do yeah that's a really good
question um i mean taysom hill first off
as you know it was phenomenal in the
preseason i mean phenomenal not just
like athletic like oh wow he's a freaky
athlete and he can make plays his
throwing and quarterback play went up
another level from what we saw as
compared to last year like he
understands how to move in the pocket
and throw a touch and you know change
arm angles and read defenses like all
that's improved to where
he certainly closed the gap between
teddy bridgewater and i would say maybe
past him now the big question is mike
first off i was shocked we didn't see
him a little in the game
you have an interesting theory and my
theory is a little bit was the first
thing is you know i think sean payton if
he did have a taste of hill package when
ooh i might have to make this guy my
starting quarterback in a week or two
and i don't want to do the taysom hill
package now and have him run between the
tackles and get killed by aaron donald
or whatever it may be
now the other theory could also be gosh
i'm down to two quarterbacks and he's my
backup and i need to keep him healthy
just in case something happened to teddy
bridgewater too so it could be either
way but i would think with the way the
preseason unfolded and as average as
teddy bridgewater looked in pre-season
and yesterday that taysom hill the
starter has got to be in sean payton's
mind a little bit at a minimum you get
both guys ready and you use both guys
because that puts more pressure on the
defense at a minimum yeah i'll take some
help right you get him out there right
you do it with drew brees yeah you're
going to get him out there with teddy
bridgewater if teddy bridgewater is the
starter here's what sean payton said
about taysom hill last month in
comparing him to steve young your guy my
buddy mr lazy fair
fair john payton said if you look back
at steve's career people don't remember
the time before he came to the nfl you
have a very athletic player that i think
advanced when he got to san francisco he
always had great ability with his legs
so you're trying to create visions for
players and that's no different than how
you evaluate how we see teddy
bridgewater progressing and what we
think he can be that's the business
we're in the bottom line is restrained
effort by sean payton to say i got a
lump of clay here yeah they could be
pretty damn good if i shape it the right
way and peyton is a master of studying
everything that happens in the nfl
cherry picking ideas that he thinks will
work with his personnel and putting his
players you talked about this with the
49ers where guys are wide open that's
great coaching yeah sean payton is great
at that play selection play design right
using the plays at the right time
setting up a defense and springing guys
wide open so i could hit the guy yeah so
you know it could be bridgewater it
could be hill right but if you have that
that car at a minimum of combination
yeah maybe take some hills of the guy at
a minimum you got to get him on the
field and i like your theory that they
kept him off the field yesterday because
he may be the starter and they didn't
want to lose two guys in the same day
against the rams i i i think it just you
know trying to put myself in his shoes
and again we don't know we're
speculating but i would think that's the
logic there and really honestly again
i'm not trying to be like negative
towards teddy bridgewater but i think
the ceiling's higher with taysom hill
and what he can do with that offense and
what i've seen to this point and i know
teddy bridgewater is a fine player but i
think he's really
a backup he's a career backup in my eyes
where i look at taysom hill like you're
saying a lump of clay where i go there's
a chance he could be steve young there
is a chance i mean there's no doubt
about it he's proven i've seen enough
already to go oh in two years he's made
giant leaps and bounds and quarterback
play and the way he throws and all those
things to make me think that
something special might happen here and
i think sean payton might see that same
type of vision and he is such an amazing
athlete two years ago when he was
playing special teams that guy is so
fast makes other guys look bad right
when they watch the film
it's like other guys are in slow motion
no yeah that's just how fast taysom
hills right yeah no he is i mean he
hustles he's i mean rocked up i mean
some of the collisions you see him make
sometimes i'm just like oh my gosh he
can take he can take on linebackers like
a running back and i you know if he does
start a quarterback he's got to limit
that kind of stuff but
yeah i'll be interested to see where
this whole quarterback situation goes
for the same and here's the other thing
too now that sean payton has a new
contract jay glazer reported that on
sunday five years beyond this year six
years total of a commitment he will be
there after drew brees yeah so the
future is coming the future may be right
now right so why not fully evaluate the
guys you have and taysom hill is the guy
who's got the higher seal i think we can
agree on that yes taysom hill has a much
higher ceiling than teddy bridges yes
definitely so why not get him ready and
get him on yeah i i i i'm rooting for
that i'm not and i love teddy
bridgewater right it's a shame what
happened three years ago derailed his
career we never got a chance to see how
good he could be in minnesota that's
right but that's where he is right now
and i think taysom hill does have a
better we see that glimmer that there
could be some greatness there and we're
seeing that from dak prescott yeah
greatness is arriving right so and we we
talked about this a little bit during
the show
and and and i think of those old images
of the horse that's got the stick that
that's that carrots dangling to keep the
horse moving in the right direction
right that carrot's dangling for dak
prescott cash though and right but what
yeah it's 24 karat is that good is 24 is
the higher the higher character i think
so right yes all right anyway i don't
know hell i don't know i don't know but
uh um
what was my point oh yeah the carrots
dangling or whether it's 24 karat or or
big orange solid gold big orange bugs
bunny carrot right and if you're the
cowboys at some point do you say i kind
of like this version of dak prescott i
kind of like the chasing the cash dak
prescott do we risk disrupting it
by giving him the cash we can always pay
him at the end of the year at what point
do they just say hey one week at a time
we like it we like it we like it he's
still carrying the injury risk so we're
protected against an alex smith
situation let him keep playing like this
because it's working yeah
i mean i think it's a very real thing in
the nfl with certain players like you
know i i just know in my time up in new
england i know i've said this to you
before
that the new england coaching staff felt
that wes welker was better when he was
pissed off or mad and sometimes they
would disrespect him or maybe not give
him the credit he deserves but they knew
if he was mad and disrespected that the
next week he was going to come out and
have a phenomenal football game well
yeah there's a lot of situations like
that throughout football i don't think
dak prescott's one of those guys
and i guess the big thing is mike i mean
if it continues to go where we're seeing
it right now right i mean
just phenomenal quarterback play big
time plays i mean just big time throws
the offense looks amazing i mean if they
go 14-2
and he's in the conversation for mvp
you know what are they gonna have to pay
him mike they're gonna have to make him
the highest-paid quarterback in football
is what they're gonna have to do i think
i think he will be the highest-paid
quarterback in football if that's the
case and here's the problem you get into
i don't wanna go too far into the
contractual weeds but if the franchise
tag next year is between 25 and 26
million for quarterbacks he'd be getting
that in 2020 a 20 raise over it so put
in between 30 and 32 million for 2021
a lot of times the value of the
franchise tag drives what your long-term
deal would be but the market is so far
above the franchise tag for quarterbacks
now right i i don't i don't because
that's what he did with dez bryant
eventually they did it with demarcus
lawrence your franchise tag number and
what you're going to make over the next
couple of years determines the
foundation for your long-term contract
for daca i don't care yeah i'm i'm in
the
i'm in the equation now where we look at
30 million plus and the other side of it
too that whole new money
total value thing once you get out from
under this rookie deal
then
the the 28 29 30 million that's real
dollars that's not inflated by this
whole new money concept on an extension
it's going to get it's going to get
complicated at the end of the year if
they don't do a deal but it may be he's
holding an mvp trophy for the
negotiations or maybe he's got his
fingerprints on the lombardi trophy for
the negotiations and it could be peter
king made the point a couple of weeks
ago that this may just be another joe
flacco situation
where a guy just bets on himself cashes
in and then you force your way into
being the highest paid player in the
sport i wonder if they offered him
the same money as russell wilson right
now would he take it
you know those are just things that that
pop in 35 million a year new money yeah
i think he would thank you but here's
the thing to get the 35 million a year
in new money you're not that far north
of the jimmy garoppolo five years 27.5
million at signing it's that last
year of a rookie contract for a guy who
was a fourth round pick two million
dollars that ma and i and i know and i
because i i i can't say how i know but i
know that's complicating this
negotiation yeah okay so yeah all right
uh but yeah it may just be let it ride
because the cowboys have it working out
all right green bay packers letting it
ride offensively they've had a few good
quarters yep uh enough to be 2-0
neither game was a blowout by any
stretch but two hard-fought division
wins one on the road one at home what's
the ceiling for that offense
it's yet to be seen really i mean i
think we got a little bit better of a
picture of it yesterday because we saw
the run game we saw a few play action
passes where we went ooh okay man that
was that was nice but then it stuttered
out i mean it just sputtered out i
should say uh it really did to where
yeah i mean hey aaron rodgers he he only
completed six more six passes in the
second half for you know 60 yards
basically and that was concerning but i
think the positive thing here overall in
the big picture for the green bay
packers is this
one
we seeing a run game and that's a
vikings defense that's pretty good right
and they like to put like eight men at
the line of scrimmage a whole lot so to
be able to have a guy like aaron jones
and run for 116 is awesome the defense
for the second week in a row did a lot
of good things you know hey there were
some turnovers by green bay and some bad
things they did offensively that set up
that minnesota vikings uh offense
yesterday in general but i mean this
packers d is real so i just look at the
packers in general and if you're a
packers fan and i would go
man you should feel good you're 2-0 and
the offense and aaron rodgers really
haven't even started to click yet and i
think if there was one thing i wouldn't
be worried about eventually starting to
click it would be that part of their
football team so to say you're 2-0 your
defense playing good we're seeing a
semblance of a run game
uh that's amazing at this point i think
it can only go up from here my other big
issue mike and you know this is just
just got to find another weapon in the
past i worry about as soon as they
started doubling devonta adams that was
it it was it it was like they couldn't
find anybody else in the offense we saw
jerome allison get the touchdown pass
okay great it was a great throw he's
tall he went up and got it get all that
but they certainly need to find another
weapon in the offense to indoctrinate
him did i say that right yes thank you
into their offense and make defenses
have to worry about that guy because it
can't just be devonte adams it cannot be
they're not gonna they might
yeah they got to get somebody else that
in there to make a defense go oh we
can't always double devonte adams
because this guy's become a big part of
their offense and that's when they can
get dangerous also if you're going to
try to block a defensive end with a
tight end make sure it's not jimmy
graham what in the hell was that well
how many times did we see that yesterday
that is a pet peeve of mine i mean
because on the white board all week and
and
look we blocked them guys the meeting's
over i've blocked them oh except they're
all human and it's jimmy graham and
daniel hunter and jimmy graham is by no
means famous for his blocking and
danielle hunter is famous for his
ability to sack the quarterback can't i
don't understand you would never see new
england do that that's another thing it
reminds me of the nfc championship game
it was the play that that opened the
floodgates or contributed to it for the
eagles the the vikings put up a tight
end in motion to stop derek barnett
exactly blew past him and ripped the
ball out fumbled his hands right three
plays later down and game over yeah
right all right uh
the dolphins game over uh you don't need
a key play like that for the game to be
over the game's over the moment they
start the game
59 to 10 43 to nothing if my math is
correct and it rarely is that's 102 to
10 yeah in two weeks that's not good
yeah that's not good how bad are the
dolphins is that is your math correct
there are you sure 40 or 59 and 43 is
102 yeah you're right my mouth is wrong
did you think it was a different number
i did yeah one or two to ten
i can't add ten plus zero though yeah
that we've got yes ten points total in
two games against 102 given up how bad
are they horrible disaster
i mean i don't know
what you really look at on the roster
other than xavier howard right now and
go
okay i mean he's the only guy that's
kind of an elite player in this league
there's some good don't get me wrong i'm
not trying to disrespect everybody there
but they are
uh really underwhelming and the coaches
are trying to find their footing as well
i mean there are a lot of first-timers
you got shadow shades a first time oc
and brian flores a first-time head coach
it just looks horrible right now and you
know they're they're tanking for tua or
whatever doing something yeah there's a
new theory now let me hear this one yeah
there's a new theory it's not tank for
two it's tank for trevor tanks for
traversing your tank oh and think about
what the browns did yeah they had one in
15 and 0 and 16. yeah go 1-15 to get
miles garrett right 016 get baker
mayfield yeah i mean if you take a
quarterback with the first overall pick
in the 2020 draft who the hell is going
to block for him right laramie tunzel's
gone right so you're going to get a
rookie quarterback and he's going to get
destroyed yeah so
there there is a that this is so bad
this is so embarrassing this is such a
how deep is this bottom no one knows
type of a situation that there are
people around not in the organization
but people like grew down in that area
where part of all this they're saying
this this is a two-year tank this isn't
a one-year tank well i mean it that's
dangerous if it is a like two-year tank
that's you're you're you're playing with
fire there because
if you go 1-15 this year
and then on the second year of this tank
job goal 1 and 15 again this coaching
staff they're not going to they might
not see a third year they might not see
trevor lawrence come in the building so
you know they're they're going to have
to make some major adjustments in free
agency and draft and be aggressive to at
least give themselves a fighting chance
next year because i think if they lay
eggs like we're laying right now next
into next year and they're we just go
whoa they can't even be competitive in
some of these games then the the the
media scrutiny the
the fan scrutiny is gonna be so much
that stephen ross might have no no
choice but the the fire the staff it
becomes too much of a disaster so they
gotta right the ship a little bit here
during this season but make sure they
give themselves at least a fighting
chance for next year there are people in
the league who believe no matter what
they do no matter how it plays out no
matter how many picks they compile no
matter what they do with those picks as
long as steven ross is the owner of the
dolphins they're going to continue to be
yeah bad not that they're going to be
this bad yeah but it's not like they're
going to parlay a year or two of
historical bad into all of a sudden
competing for super bowls every year
having a team that has a franchise
quarterback i mean they haven't had one
since dan marino right i get it i
understand the value of tanking once
you're out of playoff contention i still
believe that you should try every year
to get to the playoffs and then once you
know you're going to be seven and nine
six and ten who cares if you're three
and 13 as long as your coach has job
security but you're right i mean brian
flores may be all in for this because he
knows this is what the boss wants and i
can't come out and say it right but it
could go so poorly that when it's time
to to begin to build out of it i can't
i'm sorry yeah it's you there's a taint
now right we can't keep you around yeah
that's the scary thing all right one
more topic and i'm calling an audible on
you okay talk about the cardinals we can
talk about them later in the week we
haven't talked about antonio brown today
as it relates to how he performed
yesterday and what's coming up off the
field what was your impression of him on
the field in his debut with the patriots
well i mean look at it he looked like
antonio brown you know
knowing new england how they execute up
there years of studying them on offense
no you know i would have bet a million
dollars at the start of the game they
were going to find antonio brown they
were going to silence all of that right
away let's get this guy the ball let's
show everybody our new toy it's the
start of the game
isn't that weird yeah for as insulated
as they are against it they do pay
attention to those narratives definitely
well it's just better for their football
team too because it's just okay you know
let's get him the ball early you please
him we don't have to worry about the
rest of the team or antonio on the
sidelines going when the hell am i going
to get the ball they just end all of
that and then there's no better way to
do it than in the beginning of the game
because that's when you can give antonio
a few plays to go wait these are your
plays you're going to get these within
the first two drives really study hone
in on these to where he can get all over
the details that way but look good mike
and damn they look good gronko i mean
gronko is like they don't they're just
amazing yeah what if gronk says hey i'm
ready to come back and say no yeah we're
good we're good we'll call you we're
pretty stacked in the pass game now
um off the field
the nfl will meet with brown's accuser
on monday brittany taylor who's made it
clear from the get-go she's willing to
cooperate that's one of the flaws in the
nfl's in-house system you can't force
people to cooperate but when they want
to makes it a lot easier like in ezekiel
elliott's case the accuser
was interviewed six times right by the
nfl now here's where it got interesting
yesterday because in her lawsuit she
mentions another player doesn't name
that player that other player who is a
witness to at least one of the incidents
and not a witness like he was in the
room but he's around so he can provide
some context and how they were getting
along and what he saw what he witnessed
what he may have sensed experienced etc
marquis brown the ravens receiver who is
antonio brown's cousin so he'll be
interviewed by the nfl the thinking is
he will give favorable testimony on
antonio brown's behalf but that that
that family relationship necessarily
undermines his credibility yeah it's his
cousin right he's not going to go in
there and say oh this guy oh this oh boy
you know so that cousin who he looks up
to and wants to be just like him on the
football field so um but it is somebody
other than antonio brown to the extent
it's he said she said there's somebody
else involved who can tell a story and
maybe he can tell a story in a in a
better way than antonio brown that's my
big concern from antonio brown's
perspective
and and i want to say this as
tactfully and delicately as possible
but
i've interviewed antonio brown a couple
of times we've all seen him speak and
communicate and tweet and sometimes i
think some of the things he puts on
twitter or just like a random word
generator it makes you know it's and
i don't know how good of a witness he's
going to be yeah because when he's
getting grilled by somebody i don't know
how he's going to hold up yeah right and
he's going to get angry yeah is it is he
going to i at one point chad ochocinco
was in the midst of litigation over
some issue that came up in cincinnati
and the lawyer made the quote that he's
got the mental acuity of a soap dish i
mean sometimes you get in these spots
where
you think you just show up and smile and
everything's fine it's a different world
when it's time to testify yeah whether
it's in the setting of where you're
being interviewed by the league or you
know in court and that's where this can
all go sideways and he could be telling
i mean he ultimately could be
innocent yeah but unable to get his
story out in a way that's going to
convince someone else she may be
making it all up but very compelling and
believable in how she tells her story
that's that's the rea when you s when
you step into this arena yeah right
that's part of that's just part of the
reality because somebody's going to
decide this
based upon
what you communicate or fail to
communicate is what ultimately happens
so that starts this
today the process unfolds this week and
he could end up on the commissioner
exemplist i mean just because the
patriots let him play yesterday does not
mean he's going to be good to go and if
the patriots find out something as part
of this process that they don't like
they'll get rid of him they were going
to cut him just based on civil
allegations right in a lawsuit right
criminal charges they would have cut him
yeah civil lawsuit they won't but they
can learn something through this process
and get them to say oh we're done with
this yeah i would think they i mean yes
if they learn something in the process
that they felt just damages the product
of the new england patriots and they
don't want to be associated i have no
doubt knowing able to do the right thing
and get out of the situation you know i
don't think new england would have
signed him in general if they knew about
anything nobody would yeah nobody right
so that was news yesterday oh yeah
i mean no if you'd have known about this
lawsuit if you had a copy of this
lawsuit you would not have signed him
without doing more research to make sure
that he's innocent before stepping into
this program and they're they're they're
you know again even though they're new
england and we want to hear from antonio
they're handling it the right way you
know they're not they're not letting it
be a story for their football team even
though it's a story they're doing their
best to you know
not let it get out of control and become
you know this huge blazing inferno to
where it's just on every website
everywhere and that's all we're talking
about even if it means fracturing a rule
or two like making him available during
the week making them available they
don't care though those are yes they
will they will push the envelope with
that kind of stuff to protect the
overall aura of their locker room their
team and even to protect antonio brown
to a to a certain degree just so like
you said doesn't talk himself into a
corner or say something stupid to where
that becomes a story now the patriots
have to answer that kind of crap too
well it shall continue to be interesting
as the patriots who they don't need him
it's nice to have him they don't they do
not need him no it is running extremely
well for new england breaking that
narrative that that they stink in
september and it's an extension of the
preseason and that's the time you want
to get them no you don't want to ever
get them no as long as tom brady's
playing and even without tom brady i
just feel like it's as long as bill
belichick he has figured out yeah how to
win consistently nfl he has and and we
can either accept it right and respect
it
and maybe wait for it to end so other
teams will have a chance or or we can
just continue to to try to talk
ourselves into thinking that it's just a
fluke it's not a fluke no what we've
seen the past few years is not a fluke
all right uh we're done we're done good
job today chris sims on button coming up
later today pft pm tomorrow with juju
smith schuster and tomorrow morning
another edition of pft live enjoy the
game tonight
jets2423 baby brown's 24-17 baby see
who's right tomorrow i go baker if i'm
wrong trevor if i'm wrong i won't
mention it at all everybody have a great
day i will
[Music]
you